should be a fun one we have had two
stellar pitching matchups so far on
paper this one looks pretty good as well
gary richards part of that big three at
the top of the padre rotation with chris
paddock and nelson lament is ready to go
to face aj pollock slow ground ball with
no shift it'll be tatis grab throw close
wow that first base he's more fun to
watch when he's not playing the dodgers
that was a really nice play and up comes
max muncie ground ball down the first
baseline to cronenworth who will take it
to the bag himself
two down kerner oh for eight with five
k's in this series and now three of his
last 28. on a one-two pitch turner pulls
a breaking ball towards the left field
corner that is hooking off the wall and
an extra base hit for justin turner to
keep this first inning going turner's
first hit of the series gets ballinger
to the plate with two gone here in the
first here's garrett swing of the miss
oh man what a slider what a great slider
breaking down it away from this guy
unhittable pitch double no damage
strikeout number one it's ross stripling
is off to a 2-0 start this season and
you see what he's done in his career in
san diego really impressive stuff he's
been impressive so far this year
fernando tatis jr more hype and
performing to meet that hype and exceed
it crown ball sharply in the middle
would you take a single it is a base hit
the center field tripling figures hey
not bad i'll take it it's not this home
run try i hit a piece for the two ball
clubs here in the first here's trent
grisham 2-2 pitch
and he got him with a change up now
throw down to first to tease back in
there safely tommy pham is coming up
lifts one in the air to right field
sending jack peterson back onto the dirt
of the track to make the catch in front
of the wall tatis is tagging up and he
heads to second he will get there
aggressively well peterson kind of going
backwards
and his momentum taking it backwards
towards the wall tati's figured he could
get there and he did in the scoring
position now with two down as manny
machado comes up out of the cleanup spot
tonight breaking ball call strike three
see you later
beautiful curve for stripling two
strikeouts in the first
as chris taylor comes to the plate
richards winds and fires taylor lifts a
fly ball to center field for grisham
who's going back on it to the track at
the wall he leaps and it hits off his
glove taylor's got a triple tough to
call that ball that trent grisham missed
right there of the mistake and i think
he will tell you he should have caught
the ball the dodgers have taken
advantage of these mistakes and jock
trying to take advantage of it here
again peterson drives about a left
center field towards the gap and towards
the wall and gone
line drive of a home run for jack
peterson the dodgers lead it to nothing
and again you go back to the play that
grisham did not make if you have the
opportunity to make that play you'd
better make that play because that is
the kind of thing that could happen
here's what myers ross ahead of them
here o2 with a fastball away and a
fastball in
and a curveball gets him looking that's
the third strikeout for stripling two
out nobody on greg garcia coming up
three two comes home yeah 95 again but
this one in the zone for strike three
and stripling's fourth k over the first
two innings
off of hedges glove and peterson moves
into scoring position the dodgers get
another gift from the padre the hitter
is will smith out of the eighth spot
punches one right center field on comes
grisham lays out took a gamble and won't
get it peterson will score easily but of
course that is not a run scoring hit if
not for the past ball the dodgers take a
three to nothing lead kiki hernandez in
the nine spot bounces one along third
that's inside the bag and fair down into
the left field corner second run of the
fifth the dodgers lead four nothing top
of the order aj pollock and pollock
with a fly ball into shallow center
field grisham a late start
and making an over the shoulder catch
the second baseman
jericho pro far saving the bacon of
trent grisham first walk of the night
issued by stripling it matters it brings
number 23 there fernando tatties that's
about to see stripling for the third
time in this game and generally things
have gone well for him missing a starter
third time in the game ops of over a
thousand tati stripes on the deep left
field he drives one to the moon
high deep in very good fernando stood
right at home played he absolutely knew
down to his spleen that he'd gotten all
of that what a kid what a player you
hear the padres celebrating in the
dugout
socially distant and singing real loud
the major league debut for 20 year old
luis patino and going this year ranked
27th back-to-back singles dodgers now
first and second with one out and jack
peterson coming up yeah get a real feel
for a major league lineup when you face
the dodgers oh yeah what a way to break
in
lifts the ball to right center field and
deep way back there and
gone his second home run tonight the
dodgers now lead it seven to two and a
rude welcoming to luis patino two onward
two out left hitting greg garcia coming
up garcia lights this inner right field
that's gonna get down
coming around from second base is
machado meyers are gonna try and score
all the way from first throw to the
plate is gonna hit the first baseman
muncie two runs are in good
old-fashioned game but dodgeball you're
out watch your face you're out
yeah a little bit of embarrassment right
there from hernandez runners on the
corners in two outs for manny who
represents the tying run grisham runs
from first and the pitch is low they do
not throw down to second and so trent
has his third stolen base and he called
that a strike jayce tingler's out of the
dugout and he's gone jace tingler just
ejected for the first time as a big
league manager arguing balls and strikes
in the middle of this at-bat with manny
machado a check swing tapper to first
race to the bag won by trinen who's out
of the inning here's will myers one out
base is empty the o2 meyer swings and
hammers one out to deep left field
taylor going back but this one is up and
out a home run for will myers his fourth
home run of the season and it's seven to
five here in the eighth the closer is
now in the game for the la dodgers
kenley janssen all of a sudden runners
in the corners here for the padres with
one out in the ninth inning and tommy
fam coming up fam lights this to left
field and that ball is going to get in
tatis will score so machado comes up
runners at first and third and one gone
in a 7-6 game in the bottom of the ninth
inning first pitch
line to left field taylor is there makes
the catch here's the throw to the plate
it is there and the game is over
chris taylor ends the night with an
outfield assist from left
and the dodgers take the series from the
padres